- What does it mean to live a fuller life?
- Live by your rules, nobody else's.
Not mine because I'm
fancy, not your mother's,
not the fucking world's,
your vision of your life by your rules,
every fucking day, to
me that's a full life.
♫ Me and Gary Vee up in the office,
♫ do that rapping work or do corporate,
♫ talks about ownership and leverage,
♫ 1,800 checks and
shout-out their average.
(orchestral music)
- Hi Gary.
- Hello.
- How are you?
- [Gary] I'm super well,
Victoria, how are you?
- Oh my God, I'm doing
well, it's wet out there.
- It is super wet out there.
- Buenos dias.
- Buenos dias, how are you?
- I've been told from
orientation, you can grow here
in any vertical position
you want to go in,
any department you want to go into.
What's some advice you
can give me as far as--?
- [Gary] Email Steve Babcock.
- Steve?
- Babcock.
Our chief creative officer
- [Victoria] Yes, I
follow him on Instagram.
- So email him, CC me,
say, "I met with Gary,
"I was telling him my
story, told him about this,
"you lead creative here
at Vayner, and I'd like
"10 minutes with you to tell
you what my passions are,
"so that you can create a blueprint
"of giving me the best
opportunity to being creative."
If that's what you're looking to do.
- [Victoria] Right, um, but yeah.
- It's literally like that simple.
To make such fundamental shifts,
just takes patience of
opportunity, you know?
Putting yourself in a
position for the opportunity,
and the opportunity
then presenting itself.
And so I think sometimes
that takes 18 months,
sometimes that takes eight days.
- [Victoria] Right, and by
no means, I'm in no hurry--
- [Gary] I can feel it, I can feel it.
That's the answer though.
- I genuinely appreciate
where we're at with the influencers.
I feel like I said, I
told you I like the fact
that there's so many
pots boiling all at once,
and there's so many
different things to like--
- [Gary] Yeah I don't
feel the angst from you.
- And thank you, again.
- Your welcome.
- You're welcome, such a
pleasure, have a great day.
- [Victoria] Thank you, you too.
(upbeat piano music)
- Yeah when I walked in
here my original idea was,
" Hey, I wanna ask Gary if I
could pitch him something."
But honestly I don't think that's really
the best way for me to do that.
What I realized was that
the best way to make this
time most valuable is to
ask, I guess, for
someone to call when I...
When I feel uncomfortable, when
I don't know what I'm doing
because I think that's way more important,
because the products that I'm building--
- [Gary] So that's what you want from me?
- Yes.
- Done.
- Okay.
Absolutely.
- I mean look, the most
valuable thing I have is time
where you, it would have been easier
for me to say yes to
$25,000 in seed capital
than the answer of that, but look I think,
one of the great ambitions
I have with VaynerMedia,
is that whether somebody works here
for a week and gets fired
because we hate them,
or whether somebody
works here for 74 years,
or everything in between,
like a summer internship,
that they view it as the best ROI
that they could have ever done, and so
that's why I say yes, I
mean, the answer is: sure.
- I built this with a few of my friends,
it's a leaderboard for
the 2017 flip challenge.
- [Gary] I love it.
- [Abhi] We're going to be
ready for launch on Friday.
- [Gary] I love it, I love
it, I'll get it out there.
- [Abhi] We're gonna
launch it on Product Hunt
and we're putting on a
few bells and whistles--
- [Gary] I'll make sure people see it.
- [Abhi] Yeah, so I'll
email that to you as well.
- [Gary] My inbox is open to you, brother.
- [Abhi] Absolutely, I'll email you.
- Please.
- Once I'm ready.
- Please. You got it.
- Thank you so much.
- Good to see you.
- Good to see you, too.
- I got you a little present as well--
- Thank you man.
- I'm sure lots of people
give you presents all the time--
- I'll take them.
but I think this is fitting.
- It's the love-hate Radio Raheem--
- I love it, dude, that's awesome.
I love that man, I do
love that, I do love that.
- [Leo] You probably deal with
a lot of love-hate, anyway--
- [Gary] I'm in the business of love-hate.
- [Leo] I thought it
was super appropriate.
- [Gary] I appreciate it.
What can I answer for you?
- So 95% of my time was all taken up
by law school, that first
year is super intense.
I kind of fell off the map
on social media and whatever.
- [Gary] You should just punt it.
Punt it.
- Yeah, I was gonna ask you
if you had only 5% of your
time to do something--
- Relax.
Punt it.
You can gain it back in five minutes.
You've got a task, you've
got an agenda, punt it.
- [Leo] Where do you see
cryptocurrency affecting
business in general for you,
or whether it is for countries?
- No, I think crypto is a real thing.
I haven't dug deep enough to
put my shit on the record,
but the platform, the
theory, the blockchain,
the thought of legal
transactions happening on it...
It's just very real, you
can't stop technology.
You can regulate it and slow
it down, but you can't stop it.
So, intuitively, I think it's
a game-changing technology,
but I haven't dug deep enough
to really overthink it,
or come up with smart strategies just yet.
- Do you think you'd
want to build out things
like the Alexa skills and what not first?
Or do you feel like you have to tackle
all kinds of innovation at the same time?
- No that's exactly right,
the reason I'm not looking
at VR or crypto is like,
you can only really focus,
and so for me right now,
voice is the next half decade,
and I want to be great
at it, and so that's why
I'm spending more time
on that than the others.
- Being a college
student, I go to Michigan,
I don't know if you knew that.
- I did.
- I'm studying in the
school of management.
What value can we bring to
Fortune 500 companies or startups
that can help us leverage
what we're trying to do?
Because we know we have so
many networking opportunities,
we have so many kids,
so many organizations.
How can we, as college students,
bring leverage to these
companies, or value?
- By asking the decision
maker what the fuck they want.
I believe the way winners win is by going
to other winners, and
basically framing up,
"Hey, I wanna jam with you."
However you wanna say that.
I take it in any form,
somebody may wanna take it
in a little more
professional format, right?
"I feel like I have an
unbelievable amount of knowledge
"of what's going on in
the 18 to 25 universe.
"That has to be impacting your business.
"What can I do with that information?
"How do I synthesize that into something
"that's valuable to you? Hit me back."
Literally on LinkedIn, literally on email,
literally on a DM or
private message on social.
If you just do that with Mark Cuban down,
to 337 people that you
wanna fuck with, six answer.
- How do you show them
that I actually have
networking people that I
can actually meet with,
when they don't know
anything about your college,
they don't know--
- You don't, because
you have no way to really show it,
because they don't have
time for you to show it.
I think you have to just go
with people who intuitively just
guess.
It's selling to the sellable.
Like, Justin how did you get this job?
- [Justin] It was just, I think, timing--
- Of course it's timing.
How many times did you try?
- [Justin] I was just, first
I was just communicating,
building a relationship
with you at the time,
and then just DM DM DM DM.
- [Jake] Did you DM
DRock or did you DM Gary?
- [Justin] I emailed you,
DM'd you, snapchatted you--
- [Gary] Nothing.
- [Justin] Then eventually
he responded to an email,
and CC'd DRock and then
that led to an interview.
And I just decided to
move to New York City.
- You just ask, you just ask.
- [Jake] The hardest
part is asking though?
- The hardest part is asking with class.
The amount of people watching
this on YouTube right now,
that ask me with no class,
it's all their value prop,
it's all shticky things like
"I'll help you buy the Jets."
It's all shtick, like,
"If you don't answer
this you'll regret it."
It's all posturing instead of--
People, you're posturing, YouTube.
I don't want posturing,
I want value proposition.
Whatever Justin did, to
make me send to Drock,
it probably looks something
like, "I will work for free
"for a year, and make you videos."
- [Justin] I litteraly
said like, "I'll eat shit.
"I'll eat a live turd."
Something like that.
- [Jake] That's also making
you very relatable too,
which is also a good thing--
- Yeah but it's still hard.
Last week, Justin complained
about DRock's dictatorship,
and he's right.
Do you understand? Or maybe he's wrong--
The truth is it doesn't really matter.
Eating shit sounds great in thesis,
when he wrote that
email he's like, "Yeah!"
And then when he got a
response he was like, "Yeah!"
The thought of you saying
to Mark Cuban, or Ross,
or whoever, like Puff Daddy--
It sounds great, and it's really
great for the first month,
and then it gets hard.
- It's still okay.
- I know, it's still macro
great, it can get micro hard.
- [Justin] That's true.
- How long are you in now?
- [Justin] Almost eight months.
- The things that, eight months in,
you start having those
hopes and thoughts of like--
Look I mean he wasn't filming
DailyVee eight months ago
so there are wins, and they're big wins.
If you're older like me, you see it.
It's harder when you're younger.
- [Justin] Yeah, it's just patience, dude.
- It's just fuckin' patience--
- [Jake] But no one has patience
our age, that's what I--
- By the way brother, real quick,
let me just, let me use this opportunity.
Nobody has patience, ever.
This is not a millennial thing,
There's 86-year-olds right
now, text your grandmother,
she didn't have fucking patience either.
Humans don't have patience.
It's why we reward the
patient and talented.
- With the patience, right
now, you always say that,
right now the 20 to
30-year-old is your biggest--
- High risk, high reward?
- It's high risk, high reward.
This is the time where
I could go either way,
if you said to me like,
"I'm gonna go live in
"Cambodia for a decade."
I'd be like, "I get it."
Like you'll never do it
again, I get it, I get it.
- [Jake] Isn't that sort
of against patience though?
Because patience is waiting
over time, but this is--
- No it's patience to
what you want, right?
Like actually living in
Cambodia for 10 years,
or Barcelona for 10 years, and having fun,
is the ultimate patience.
You're saying to yourself,
"I'm gonna start at 30, which means at 40
"maybe I'll have some
things going for me."
Actually, I would argue
that really having fun
for the first decade out of school,
is the ultimate patience, if
you have ambition to create--
Do you see what I mean?
- Because I was gonna ask
if that's how it is.
- Yeah.
So there's just a lot of versions of it.
You gotta make sure that your actions
map your mouth and your ambitions.
- [Jake] Okay, staying on the
same track and actually know--
- Those things have to map. Your actions,
and what you're fucking saying,
and what you're doing have to map.
So if you're like, "I'm gonna be, fucking,
"the owner of the Jets and this and that."
And you're working seven hours a week,
and fucking taking 19 years of vacation,
that doesn't look the part.
If you're saying, "Look,
"I just want to have a balanced life,
"and make a couple coin,
enough to get through."
Get through meaning make $400,000 a year,
you can work nine to five and
make $400,000 a year easy,
if you're talented enough,
developer, (mumbles)--
There's a lot of ways to do this.
My biggest thing is don't
work like me, or don't--
There's no right answer,
there's only a right answer
for you, you just have to make sure
that your North star, at all times,
and it changes at 22, and 31, and 40.
I'm about to take a
shitload of time off, right?
That's not where my mind was at 22,
but it is at 41, your
life and world change,
and you've just got to keep mapping to it,
and trading on it daily.
(relaxing guitar music)
I like August you know, I just like
that I can feel everybody's off,
and that makes me feel comfortable.
(laughter)
You know?
How was your weekend?
- It was great.
I haven't seen my sister
in a year and a half.
- [Gary] What?
- She was in Hawaii for
the last three years.
- [Gary] Wow, that's awesome.
- So it was really good.
- I genuinely believe,
over the next half decade,
that this becomes common
practice if you guys go big
like this, and people
start extending commercials
on Facebook because it makes so much sense
in today's double-screen environment.
And so, to me, that's--
And then leverage culture
to create a flame,
but to me it's all
reverse-engineering the sale.
I'm trying to create Captain and Coke.
Like, I think we have 16 at-bats
to create Captain and Coke,
because that's how you
can grow your business,
and I think that should
be the number one agenda
with a (silence) investment.
I genuinely am excited by the random idea
that it all falls apart tomorrow.
When you can get there, you have
to fall in love with the loss.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- That to me is the ultimate,
that's why I just sit like--
- [Paul] That fires you up.
- It's a great thing to fire you up about
because then you've almost
then eliminated everything.
Because it's not about,
"Okay now I'm ready to crush Georgetown,
"now I'm ready to crush this relationship,
"now I'm ready to crush this startup,
"now I'm ready to crush this job,
"now I'm ready to crush
30." It's the reverse.
Which is, "I've crushed.
"Now let's just see how
it plays out." And...
We're using a boxing reference,
since you bought up shadowboxing.
What you are, is you're
Mike Tyson right now,
you're on the offense in such an extreme.
I'm far more Pernell Whitaker,
and obviously most people
know it's Mayweather now,
I'm a counter puncher.
- What would you say is
someone, being my my age--
I'm interested in film, I
mean my mind does change
constantly but, you say
to taste everything,
but what would you advise me
to take advantage of at my age?
- To go work, and work for
free or work for money,
every six months on something different
until your thirst is quenched.
I don't think
you guys realize
how wasteful you can be with all your 20s.
In the, what everybody thinks as wasteful,
But for someone like you,
if you believe that is you,
and you know yourself
well, if it's not just you
painting that as a romantic picture
because you don't want to make a decision.
If that's really you.
Well then you should go
and do different shit
for six month intervals, forever.
Until you can't move from
the thing you're doing.
- See but then I think
there's a lot of, you know,
I wanna do something, and
I find myself loving it,
and then I find myself just
loving the next thing, and...
(stammering)
- It might be okay for
you to do that forever.
- [Claire] Just constantly changing?
- Somebody might say that
you're schizophrenic,
I would just tell you you're self-aware.
I think the biggest thing
is wrapping your head around
doing it your way, and just
blocking out everything else,
and creating a life where
you don't need the finances--
The biggest reason people
lock themselves in is
they get into a place
where their lifestyle
requires a certain amount
of income, which they can't
then get somewhere else by
leaving the thing they're doing.
If you're making $113,000
a year being a something
at a New York City Office,
and you're living a $113,000 lifestyle,
it's hard to go make $54,000
being an art assistant.
- My big thing is to go the reverse.
Really, really live
humbly in your twenties
to allow you to do all those things,
because then it may unlock
the love of your life,
creatively and career wise,
which will then always lead
to your biggest economic opportunity,
or just life opportunity.
Even if the max of the
economics is 80,000,
nobody at 90 years old wished
they'd made more money,
they all just wished they were happier.
- So what do you advise, you mean in film?
What would you advise me to--?
- [Gary] Cold-email every
single film person on earth
until one of them gives you a job.
- Just like--?
- Just like that.
- And in terms of creating my own content,
I mean you throw out millions
of things of content, just
make my own content, right?
- Do that. Right.
Literally you should email
Steven Spielberg and be like,
"Can I intern for you for free?"
I highly believe you'll
not get a response,
but I think you will somewhere,
and if just Judd Apatow's in
the mood that day, that's life,
and then you go out there and
sleep on somebody's couch,
that you met on Craigslist.
And then you wake up
nine months later and go,
"I want to live in
Mexico and make tequila,
and then you DM every
single person on Instagram
that has a tequila account
and say, "I wanna work for--"
The words "I wanna work for
free" get peoples' attention
that matter, because
whether they want the free,
or it speaks to a hunger, and ambition,
it always attracts an A-player.
Everybody gets fancy and
thinks they're worth something
because they fucking went
to Harvard or Penn State,
or made 60 videos on
YouTube that did well.
Everybody thinks they deserve something.
I, at this point of my career,
believe I deserve nothing.
That's the fundamental mindset.
That's the difference between
the winners and losers.
- They have to create a
vlog every day for a month,
they're following a
comedian on a tour bus,
and they're running from
California to New York--
Yeah it is, but it's not,
because we just need one person.
- [Gary] Where's Jake, is Jake out there?
- Yeah, uh.
- Yell for his name.
- [Employee] Jake, Jake!
- They need to pump out
an episode every day,
and they need to live on
a tour bus for a month.
- You wanna do, when is it?
From when to when?
- October.
- The whole month of October?
- Whole month of October.
- Hey Jake.
- What's up.
- It's a band?
- Nope, it's a comedian.
- Good.
- So you're interested?
- Yeah.
Good we might have to do a coin flip now.
Nate you got one?
(coins jingling)
Jake do you want to spend
the entire month of October
on a comedian's tour
bus, to pump out, talk.
- [Employee] A daily episode of a vlog
that centers on the comedian, and about
hearing disability awareness.
- [Jake] I'm interested.
- Great, you too? Great.
Jake, because I've known you longer,
you get to call heads or tails.
- [Jake] Tails.
- Can somebody please record this.
(mumbling)
Ready, one more time, this
is, this is, this is a--
You got what?
- Tails.
- Tails, all right. "Tails never
fails" is your theory here?
Somebody's going on a comedian tour bus
for the whole month of October.
(coin bouncing)
Heads, Justin's going.
- [Justin] See ya!
- Bye Justin!
- Cool, see you Justin.
- Who's the comedian?
- Cool, set it up.
- Do you know who the comedian is?
- [Gary] Kevin Hart?
(laughter)
(relaxing electronic music)
- Nate you're good at
ping pong and then, Alan,
I just wanna make sure
you throw, I wanna throw,
I want you to throw some finance person--
- [Dennis] I'm better than Nate.
- [Nate] That's just nonsense.
- [Gary] Do you think you're
good at ping-pong, Dennis?
- [Dennis] Oh yeah brother.
- Everyone thinks they're--
- Okay no, listen, listen,
Justin's in a room, Justin
versus Nate, ping pong
at this place on 23rd, and
Justin's gonna film it for me.
I wanna see it while I'm on vacation.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Nate, important question:
have you ever beaten me in tennis?
- [Nate] No, have you ever
beaten me playing golf?
- No, but what's our golf record?
(laughter)
I think I'm like 16/0, 13/0, 11/0,
something like that, in tennis.
And I think you're like
2/0 in golf, probably.
- Listen, everyone wants
to think they're good
at ping pong, until they get in the ring.
- [Gary] Yeah everybody's gotta play
until they get punched in the mouth.
I understand what you tried
to say there Nate, good try.
- [Nate] I wasn't going with the quote.
- Yeah you were, you didn't
realize it, it was subconscious.
- [Nate] I didn't even know that quote.
- [Gary] I know you
didn't, but it was still--
You were heading in that direction.
(arguing)
See you.
- You know what's funny,
there's a lot of talk--
What did I hear is a young man's game,
50-year-old, who was this?
Ah, The Defiant Ones, did you
watch that documentary yet?
- Oh yeah.
- You know when, when uh,
when Dre is like, "Music's
a young man's game."
it was interesting, it's interesting,
I really think a lot of 20 to 35 year-olds
underestimate their pulse on society.
And that's what this just reminded me of.
A lot of the ideas that kids
have are actually right,
they just don't know
how to make businesses.
- [Kenny] Sure, the
experience is not there yet.
- They just don't know,
yeah, or the talent--
Like, I was 22 and knew how
to make businesses, right?
So you're right it's either
the experience or the talent,
it's no different than being a crafty vet,
or coming in the league
at 18 and being dominant.
It's one of those two, right?
- Mm hm. Yeah.
- Or both like Vince Carter, right?
And then that's why you have
a 25-year career, right?
And that's it, man, that's
my answer to that question,
that's the best way I
could answer that question.
(calming music)
Let's have this conversation right now.
(exotic calming music)
("Ash" by Rothstein)
♫ I don't say much. I'm in the zone.
♫ Drinking my cut. And it's my chi.
♫ Momma, I just gotta manage it now.
♫ Remember when I caught champion sound?
♫ I was in fifth grade, mix tapes
♫ best friends handing me down
♫ Became my gospel. Wouldn't
make a fan of me now.
♫ I know too much, that's
why I don't say too much.
♫ It's the problem with you rappers,
♫ You play too much, weigh too much,
♫ I don't really pray too much,
♫ Because I ain't got the
light to wait too much.
♫ And Momma I know,
♫ I was never meant to
make it on the South side.
♫ Because my skin ain't
thicker than some cow hide.
♫ Rappers line up for a
ticket with your mouth wide.
♫ Bossman tell you to jump
you will say how high.
♫ All that fake shit tickle me now.
♫ All my best friends sick of me now.
♫ All my ex girls figure me out.
♫ All my new girls kicking me out.
♫ I don't care what you
think of me now, I know.
♫ Momma I know.
- [Gary] So people don't wanna
tell me things that are bad
because they think I'd be
upset, I'm the reverse.
I only want to know what's bad,
because I know I'm the
quickest path to fix.
And so like, "This
sucks, and this sucks--"
And listen, it can be exhausting,
and if somebody's just doing
it because that's their nature,
well they're gonna lose,
but if you're like,
if you're like, "This is good, this--"
If it's critical thinking,
you know I wanna hear it.
People think they're a tattle,
or they're a Debbie Downer,
I just got done telling Marcus
everything's broken here,
because I believe that,
but I also know equally,
everything's working here,
we're the fastest growing
thing of our nature
in the market, you know,
there's a lot of good.
So like, you know, life.
- [Christian] Yeah.
Cool.
- What are you into outside of work?
- I like to write.
Right, write music, cool man.
- That's pretty much all I do.
- [Gary] Is that right,
That's like your jam?
- That's my jam, that I thought
I would become an artist.
But I don't know if that's the path
that I'm trying to go down.
- Have you ever, I've got an idea for you.
Advice I gave a kid that
really worked for him.
I think you should DM every single artist,
and just DM them the full lyrics--
You should write, what
kind of music do you write?
- [Christian] It varies, well,
I write for different people
but I also write for myself, so.
- And perform? You ever put any of it out?
- No, but that's one of my goals--
- Let me do something real nice for you,
you write and perform
something and put it down,
I'll use it in my vlog,
it will get real exposure.
- Okay, thanks man, I appreciate that.
- You're welcome, dude hit me up,
let's make this living
and breathing, you know.
(gentle guitar music)
- This is so cool just to
see how it all operates.
- How the sausage gets cut?
- It's unbelievable,
it's a dream come true,
not many people get together
and see the inner-workings--
How's your day going?
- Well, busy.
- That's nothing new though, right?
- That's the norm, that is the norm.
- So you doing the meet and greet tonight?
- Yeah, you gonna come?
- Of course, my profile's
called Find Me In Seattle,
my dream one day is to be able to say,
"I'm right here. Come here right now,
"and you get free stuff to
the business that I'm at."
And so, I get that from you,
because it's unbelievable
how many people you get to turn up
just by saying, "I'm gonna be here."
(laughter)
Hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuck,
and this is episode 262 of the AskGaryVee
show,
and I'm pretty excited about this.
Ryan Holiday is in the house,
I know that a lot of
you are humongous fans
of this man's work, I've
seen his name pop up now for,
it feels like about half a decade,
I like saying that instead of
five years, I'm not sure why,
It's so crazy, I don't give a shit
what Drake has to say now,
I would watch every
minute of the three years
before he became Drake, all of it.
I would consume all of it.
Show me the day before it happened,
and then you realize it's not a day,
the biggest reason I'm
doing DailyVee is because,
guys, YouTube, it's not a day
before, it's the whole thing.
It's just a volume of work that shows you
it wasn't a moment,
it was the whole fucking
thing, the whole process.
- I carry in my pocket
every day, I carry a coin,
that just says memento mori,
which is Latin, it means
remember your death, right?
And on the back there's a
quote from Marcus Aurelius,
the Stoic, and he wrote
to himself, he said,
"You could leave life right now,
"let that determine what
you do and say and think."
So this could be the last
show I'm on in my life,
this could be the last
city I'm on in my life,
this could be the last book I ever write,
the last time I talk to my wife,
it could be the last time--
And you gotta let that determine ever--
You've gotta let that
shape, death should--
The thought of your mortality and death,
in a, not in a depressing way,
should shadow everything that you do,
because it's the only way to
make sure you do it right.
- Boy do I talk of death,
about death a lot, right?
I mean, the funeral, I
believe in it the most
as you can probably know a little bit.
I love, I'm glad you brought that up.
- Know your three words, you're gonna die.
That should let you cut out
bullshit, that should let you
decide how you're gonna
treat other people,
and let yourself be treated,
and it should determine
the quality of the work
that you're gonna do.
- This happens to everybody
in a micro, it's called--
When police lights go on behind
you, you're scared shitless,
you change your behavior,
then the car drives by you,
and then for like three minutes,
you're like, "Okay, I'm gonna go 55 now."
And then you know four minutes
later you're going 73 again.
And that's how I think
people do it in life,
something bad happens,
they hear something,
they see something and
they're like, "Oh, shit,
"I'm gonna live under the
mindset of you're gonna die."
They've seen my thing,
they've hit them, for a day.
- It's like, you hear about
a friend that has cancer
and you think, "What would
I do if I had cancer?"
You do have cancer,
you're gonna fucking die,
you do have cancer, you
just don't, you just don't--
First off because lots
of people do get cancer,
so there's a real chance
that the cells are already in
your body, right, but like
you do have a fatal diagnosis
from a doctor, he just can't
tell you if it's six months
or 60 years, but you are
definitely, 100%, going to die.
And it could be tomorrow.
So what are you gonna do
with that information?
- I believe in it the most, my man.
Blurry.
Perfect.
- Thanks man.
- Guys, one life, baby, one life,
do something about it please.
Please use this video to
do something about it.
- Thank you very much.
- Alright man,
take care of yourself
I hope you enjoyed it.
- [Jeff] One time I went
to school up in Boston
but then was living back
in Miami, I was doing
the travel-life for work,
as I'm sure you know.
- I get it.
- I'm curious, actually, how
many miles you did last year,
but I did 200,000--
- Tyler!
Do we have any feel on how
many miles I do a year?
- [Tyler] Uh, miles, top line, no.
But you did like 165 flights last year.
- Got it, cool, thanks.
(laughter)
I'm sure there's plenty.
- Yeah, right?
- [Jeff] Um, so yeah it
means being able to--
- Jesus Christ that's a
lot of fucking flights.
My big thing, like if you
really want the real hack,
my big hack is I just
think we're letting things
never see the day of light at scale,
like today there was 11 pieces of content
that are rip-shit fucking
winners. No prayer.
Nope, will never seen, will not be seen.
I've said this a million times,
this is all we talk about
at this point, me and DRock.
I met 17 fucking interns
today, there's four
phenomenal fucking podcasts
of advice that will kill.
We have no prayer of any of
them seeing the day of light.
And like six unbelievable clips that
are over a million organic reach.
No prayer. And eleven quotes, no prayer.
Just we have no, we have
no system for capturing
the sawdust, which is like
why when you hang there and--
We're gonna have to,
that's the number one hack.
But listen, that's fine when I'm here.
What is there gonna be
another fucking person now
that we travel with, who's
just there to, to produce?
Maybe? Maybe that's why there's
producers, I don't know,
but I know one thing, every day
we are missing out on 13 things
that never become real.
And so what happens is
my Facebook, and my podcast, is
is to me stale,
versus all the freshness
that comes out daily,
and that's that, and
that system will work,
unlike Colin where he needs
me for the long form content,
like the clips, and
like the transcriptions,
and like the podcast original.
That's where we have
to hack, and honestly,
even more than ever
before right this second,
I think maybe it is the producer.
It's just too much, like I
know what happened today.
And it's 15 really good
things, and I'm gonna get one.
That's just stupid,
that's just not achieving
the infrastructure we have.
So I don't know what
everybody takes away from that
but we need to figure that out.
How many meetings did I have today?
- [Justin] You've probably gone through--
- Well, how many did I have today,
40--?
- 40 total, top to bottom.
- Guys, 6:56 p.m.
We've got one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine more meetings to go.
It's been a pretty active day.
You learn something today, Justin?
- Yep.
- What?
Yeah now you're in trouble, you knew that,
you knew that already.
(laughter)
Anyway, that's the little YouTube update.
The YouTube 6:55, 6:56 p.m. update.
Let's make this a thing!
Let's always update YouTube at 6:56.
On the way to the Dirty Lemon event,
Phil and I made an
investment in that company,
direct to consumer, CPG brand,
gonna do a guest bartending.
I just found out I don't have
to bartend, which is huge,
but lots of high fives, and selfies,
and answering business questions,
which is fine by me,
exactly how I like it so,
I hope I see you guys, it's
raining here in New York so,
hopefully a couple of people will show up.
("Mojito Purpleafterparty"
by PURPLE AFTERPARTY)
♫ We gonna dance anyway.
♫ I know there's bills on the way.
♫ So we gonna dance anyway.
♫ You know that bill's only way.
- What does it mean to live a fuller life?
- Live by your rules, nobody else's,
not mine because I'm
fancy, not your mother's
not the fucking world's,
your vision of your life by your rules,
every fucking day, to
me that's a full life.
- Yo, fucking Gary Vee
it's so great to meet you.
I have the earpiece right
now because I'm at work,
I'm probably getting fired,
but I don't give a fuck!
I wanted to see you and
I had to make it happen.
- Thank you my man.
- I'm a rapper,
I got my first song on iTunes right now,
it just got onto the streaming services,
it's PURPLE AFTERPARTY,
my content is amazing.
I'm in a uniform but my
tattoos and everything,
my image is the shit,
I'm networking every day.
My dream is to be on GaryVee,
on one of the vlogs, my song,
I'm probably gonna get fired at my job,
I had to come here.
- It's done.
- Oh my fucking god,
man, you the fucking man.
I was risking my job,
risking my job to reach you--
- It's done, it's done.
- Gary I really appreciate
it, besides that,
I can't even believe you're doing this.
What's two cents that
you think I should do
to give me the upper hand?
- More songs, DMing more people.
- Okay, yeah I watch you like every day,
you just liked my comment when I wrote,
when you were with Nifty Hustle.
- Yep.
- And I was like,
fucking great minds, dude,
you're one of the people
that really got me motivated, so,
say I'm chasing what I fucking love?
- Go at it.
- I really appreciate it dude
thank you so much brother.
Thank you, Gary.
- Connect with Justin.
- So I'm from the midwest,
caught about 60,000,
working with one of my buddies to start up
a local advertising kinda
deal, for smaller businesses.
I'm really looking to
influence the marketing,
but I'm having a hard
time thinking of ways
to find those influencers
in such a small town.
- You go, easy, what's the
zipcode of your small town?
- 54703.
- 54703?
- Yep.
(club music)
- There's your influencers.
- That easy?
- That easy!
- That easy.
So when you click, this dude
posted this in that town,
you click him, he's got 1,500 people,
you hit this DM, and you just
literally say to him, "Yo."
- Do I offer him money or what's the deal?
- Why don't you just say, "Yo."
and you're trying to build a relationship?
Like I just did, because literally
I just typed in the zipcode,
right, these two girls, right?
She's got 882 followers, right?
But she's cute, so you can use her, right?
Right? This dude, 1,500 followers.
There it is!
- Awesome, appreciate it so much.
- Being a fucking practitioner,
that's the fucking game.
When you can answer questions right
on the fucking spot, in detail.
- I flew from Chicago two
hours ago, I jumped on a plane,
- Unbelievable.
- I wanna show you,
I'll call you right
back, I wanna show you.
So literally this is when I woke up,
and he's like, "Yo, can
you take me to New York?"
That was my Uber, and that
was my flight and my Uber,
this was five hours ago, got here, yeah.
- Let's do the payoff!
He fucking made it!
- We made it!
- Got here on time.
- We made it.
- I'm out of time, I wanted--
- The audio?
- I was hoping that you could
give me a personal message to
motivate me in the morning?
- What's your biggest thought? I got it.
My man, I'm gonna make
this real fucking simple,
I'm gonna make this real simple.
What if today was the
last day you woke up?
What are you gonna do about it?
Go do that.
- We're creating a podcast
to really get people in,
to talk about biohacking,
and best practices.
I could really like use
your help, pick your brain,
on how to launch it, I
got some pretty big guests
lined up for it.
- It's all guests,
it's all guests, and it's
you being guests on others
and it's Facebook ads driving
people to the podcasts,
and it's influencer marketing, that's it.
Guests, you being a guest, Facebook ads,
influencers on Instagram.
It's a wrap, now go do it.
That's the strategy.
How good are you at asking 8,000
people to be on their show?
Good to see you man, how you been?
- Been good, man.
- Good man. Grinding?
- Right, speaking gigs
today, and just last week,
and tomorrow.
- I'm proud of you man.
Staying to see it,
consistency consistency,
I see you grinding out there.
- Yeah, appreciate it.
- Thanks for coming by.
- Yeah, absolutely,
I had to see you I was
like, "Wait a minute,
"I'm not gonna see him
again till Big Summit."
So thanks for coming out.
- Good to see you man, you good?
- Good, could we get a--
- Yeah, yeah.
My man, great to see you,
keep doing your thing.
- Andres, could you tell him
(speaking in foreign language)?
- Andres, (speaking in foreign language).
Patience, baby! (speaking
in foreign language).
- I appreciate, man.
- I know yesterday, this is Miguel.
- Miguel, it's so nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, finally.
- After all those nice
things I said about you,
it's nice to meet you. How have you been?
Good, good.
- I've been good!
- I live right up the street,
so I was like, "I have to go.
"I like have no reason not to go."
Snap this pic with Miguel.
- Let's do it.
Keep hustling, baby!
(distant shouting)
- [Fan] I couldn't fucking leave,
I told you I was gonna
leave but I couldn't leave.
- [Gary] You changed your mind.
- [Fan] Yeah I figured
I'd just stick around
and talk to the crowd, it was pretty good.
- [Gary] Good, man, real pleasure, now.
("Mojito Purpleafterparty"
by PURPLE AFTERPARTY)
♫ You know there's bills on the way.
♫ We gonna dance anyway.
♫ I know there's bills on the way.
♫ So we gonna dance anyway.
♫ You know that bill's only way.
I think I can do selfie from here on out.
Wrapped up a long goddamn day,
seven, eight more meetings.
11:33 p.m.
Solid fucking day.
Hustle.
("Mojito Purpleafterparty"
by PURPLE AFTERPARTY)
♫ I like the way you walk,
you got that attitude.
♫ Making big waves, you
like we up in Malibu.
♫ Feelings that we know,
or that should we Goku.
♫ Now I'm super saiyan with
the bread, like I'm Goku.
♫ Baby you been working
so hard I promote you.